it's been a while since we've seen this
man and he is a sight for sore eyes
despite the Psychopaths that he plays on
The Walking Dead which returns for
season behind on Sunday October 7th that
90s Cantonment AMC good to see you
Jeffrey Dean Morgan how are you sir I'm
really good now now when people see you
do they get scared just looking at you
because of how you play me sometimes
yeah yeah I don't know if they get as as
scared as maybe they do get angry but he
always I guess I always elicit some sort
of reaction certainly interesting angry
yeah how you act as a being when you act
that's it
that's it angry at the character that I
play but that translates to being mad at
me a guy walking down the street with
sometimes with my little boy you know
yeah he's eight yeah I'm gonna
eight-year-old and he can see him coming
before I do ghusl look up and he goes I
know this person's gonna stop your dad
or he's like let me guess he's gonna be
coming up and he'll say let me guess you
want a selfie yeah yeah it's pretty
funny it's very funny more often than
not he is absolutely correct yeah do you
have a policy on your eight-year-old
watching The Walking Dead yeah he
doesn't know he doesn't watch it now
he's seen like clips stuff on like
YouTube I've taken him to the set so he
knows a lot he knows all the actors
involved and he knows that I'm the bad
guy of the show okay but yeah he's aware
but he certainly hasn't seen it he's
seen clips with it it doesn't involve
blood and guts okay yeah so but your
eight-year-old has been exposed to
Seattle Seahawks football absolutely
okay since the minute he was born yeah I
think his first outfit was the Seahawk
onesie yes no choice no choice so where
do you stand get your from the Seattle
area yeah yeah where do you stand on the
current state of the Pete Carroll
Seattle Seahawks I think you know I'm I
am not prepared to admit that we're in
any kind of a building year a rebuilding
year but it's been a tough it's been a
tough couple years in
as a fan I hate seeing what's going on I
think the the Earl Thomas thing has been
a little bit heartbreaking not that I
don't understand both sides it to a
certain degree but we're talking about a
Hall of Fame player and if we lose him
if John and Pete let him go I think
that's gonna be a thing that's gonna be
hard to forgive for us fans it seems
right now with Earl Thomas that whatever
is going on and there is definitely
something going on because normally guys
who are won a new contract and they
might hold out and then they report
everything kind of waits till the end
that's right but there's something going
on there's something going on but if
that something leads to to interception
is on a Sunday three in three games
that's you know and you sit there and
think if there's anybody who could kind
of navigate all that it it's Pete
Carroll I would think so I mean you know
that Pete's always been such a s a
player's coach not that you know when
Marshawn was part of the team he kind of
did his own thing too and Pete has
always been really good at letting his
big personalities kind of do their thing
and I know that you know Earl gave an
interview after the Dallas game saying
you know he he is betting on himself so
if he has a headache or whatever it may
be and he's not showing up at practice
my feeling is if that's not affecting
the team if the other players are okay
with that and he shows up on a Sunday
and intercepts two passes then we're
gonna keep him I mean you'd be crazy to
even think about dealing him away not to
say that my heart didn't break in a
thousand little pieces when I saw him
chasing down the Dallas coach last year
down that tunnel and saying hey come and
get me and I killed me I want him to
retire a Seahawk but there's been so
many changes and I think all those
changes we can we can go right back to
not giving Marshall on the ball on the
1-yard line in that supergirl by the way
the way you just
it's just it's it still is a wound that
has not been cauterized I don't know
that ever will be yeah yeah it's painful
they're not and and what's happened
since then
you know I think Pete maybe lost a
couple of his players as far as them
believing in him
I think Sherman was one of them I think
I think he definitely was one of them
evil definitely has come out cliff raver
was not with the team anymore he
definitely came out you me he's
verbalized yeah Michael Bennett I mean a
couple of our big important cogs in the
wheel I think that have now left have
been very kind of verbal about that very
moment
marShon I I think it hurt I think you've
heard not just us but a lot of the
players well I mean that part look I
understand that players would be upset
about not going to a bread and butter
right when you're talking about game on
the line Super Bowl on the line and hold
on a second I don't mean I'm not rubbing
it in when I say there's no no I
okay but legacy right dynasty dynasty
yeah back to back yeah on the line that
you go away bread and butter yeah and it
was a great play by Malcolm Butler it's
like Russell misplaced the ball I mean
you could say phenomenal play right from
out that you got beat yep I just don't I
don't know if I buy that that play call
was made or okayed by Carroll because
they didn't want Marshawn to have the
spot I don't know that I believe that
either some of the players do yeah some
of the players do I look I mean I will
never know my truth behind that but
that's that's a that's a tough way to
that's a that's your jump into a pretty
big conclusion but I you know look I'm
not in that locker room and I don't know
know why yeah
my guess is he wanted to win that game
just as much as the rest of us as well
as Russell and everyone else I mean who
knows but but give Marshall on the ball
Jeffrey here on the Rich Eisen show
again The Walking Dead returns season 9
on AMC October 7th 9th and Tom's you
ever play sports yourself yeah yeah I
played I played everything as a kid
growing up but I was really a basketball
player in high school and you know had
scholarship offers in the whole of nine
played some football and then I stopped
playing football after my junior year
because I was breaking my fingers and I
didn't want to mess up my basketball hmm
but then I blew my knee and I've had
like seven surgeries and well I mean
just the way you handle a bat on the
walking dead and swinging a bat yeah I
mean how are you as a baseball player I
know I never loved baseball as much as
other sports but also you know when
you're playing Little League it's not
the most exciting probably the sport in
the world and back when I play there
certainly was an ET ball so I remember
playing when I was just a kid and
getting hit in the head constantly with
pitches and you know that was a little
out of control but you're asking like a
seven-year-old to pitch the ball do you
know what we have you know Mike you boy
you're talking my language here I mean
my seven-year-old played this year yeah
okay
and they made the kids pitch to each
other and I'm like what are we doing
here especially cliff my kid got hit in
the last game of the year yeah and he
got hit and he went down he started
crying and I was the dad who came out
from the bench to make sure he was okay
and then the UMP told him to take his
base and I told the UMP I actually did
this on planet Earth I told the UMP
okay so in a pony baseball game let him
hit again like what what why don't we
what are we trying to teach him all of
them in the rule that you hit you go to
first right and then I realized I'm that
dad right now that's okay your dad
absolutely a hundred percent agree in
and back that play back it I'll back it
all day long
I don't know if you know it's but that's
as you not as negan correct this is me
this is me I mean I'm but my little boy
is playing soccer right now yeah mine
too
yeah
I love minutes you know it's like it's
like a hive of bees you know but
following around the ball exactly but
it's so much fun he's in his third year
and playing and and seeing the
improvement every year is is is a lot of
fun and and I I'm the happiest guy in
the world watching my kid play sports so
how are you right now with this show man
I mean this show is as red hot as ever
The Walking Dead
your character is in a different
predicament yeah and people who have
been rooting for your vicious demise
yeah yeah I mean you know it's it's like
a 50-50 I think 50% of people are ready
for negan to meet a grisly end and and
the other 50% are liking negan and want
to see certainly what else that can
happen here like hoping you think some
of fans are hoping that you turn into
the nice guy oh absolutely yeah I think
I think that they're hoping for some
redemption and in the comic book there
is a slight amount of redemption I I
don't know what we're gonna how we
follow that story and if we will because
we do switch enough from the comic book
to keep people that are fans of the
comic interested in the show but it's
certainly been an interesting year
playing the different sides and finding
new new shades of negan and and I very
much have enjoyed that but it's a it's a
different year we've got new writers and
showrunners and you know everybody knows
that that Andy's going to be leaving at
some point this year Rick Grimes so it's
a different year but I'm very excited
about it I think that the show the story
in the writing is has been top-notch
this year and I'm very excited what are
the fans to see what's it like for you
when you get a script what do you do
with it I'm not even looking for
specifically I'm looking to see if I'm
in it one see if see if I'm meeting a
demise you know you don't know know no
one tells you much on the show come on
yeah yeah you like that no I hate it I
hate it you know III I believe in kind
of giving the actors as much information
as possible from
it certainly helps us as actors figure
out what our arc is for the year right
like if you can tell me at the beginning
that you're kind of where I'm gonna end
up the year that helps me as an actor
kind of create the story that I need to
in each scene but not knowing it's hard
it's hard because you want there that
you want everything to kind of connect
and make sense and this shows never been
really big on just because the nature of
the beast and how many people would love
to kind of spoil it for other people
we keep everything very tight and top
secret well if you don't like it
Geoffrey you want you just show up on a
Friday say I have a headache and just
you know and then just show up yeah
you're seeing yeah yeah and just you
know that's gonna do it all Tom it's not
a I mean it's working it's working damn
it how would that work on a set though
my co actors either difference between
football and the rest of the world you
know I guess I think this is a situation
that we're talking about I mean I think
he's so loved by his teammates and the
12 and the 12 and he is obviously very
effective on Sundays and and I think
that has been proven this year it
doesn't matter if he shows up Rex or not
he's still our best defensive player and
he is all over the field that being said
I really think that we should get him a
long-term contract you would do it yeah
yeah I would I think he deserves it man
I do not know what is gonna happen I
don't either
i I really don't every day I kind of
wake up and wonder did it happen is he
going you know well he instagrammed out
a photograph of himself that picture of
him taking a bow after he he bowed bowed
to the dollar's after he picked it off
yeah and he bowed down yeah okay and he
put that on his Instagram and the copy
was someone's gonna write the check I
know who I wanted to be but he also said
they'd be prior to the
this game the coaches were coming up to
him from Dallas saying are you ready for
the trade on Monday what could be the
Chiefs - they're not they boy I would
not want that to happen Chiefs are
looking good this year you know I could
use a blow your your buddy Paul Rudd
yeah a neighbor Paul Rudd said he would
he would love all time and I'd never
friggin hear the end of it so I really
really don't want that to happen that's
true and I tell you I love watching
Holmes my god that guy is just lighting
it up he's dynamic yes and also how cool
is it to see Cleveland win a game I've
never like gotten off my chair and
rooted for another team ever in my life
until Thursday night when Cleveland was
flying well Jeffrey Dean Morgan speaking
on behalf of all jet fans as I was yes
growing up as one I have a different
point of view on that yes I really think
you're gonna be okay though I think the
Jets
I like Donnell a lot I do too I totally
understand why anybody who has no skin
in the game if you would look at that
guy you felt what was happening yeah the
television sure did and he has it he is
dynamic he is exciting and in the same
way that Jets fans felt about darn 'old
week one and clearly Browns fans felt
about mayfield or Chiefs fans feel about
mo home yeah you had that sensation when
Russell Wilson yeah danger everybody
wants a piece like that yeah every fan
one well I think you certainly have
something to build on and I mean he is a
talent and he's a kid I mean you've tend
to forget that this guy's you know 21
years old and and but he's got an arm on
him he's a big guy he hasn't been paying
football that long really you know so
III think you know I think the Jets are
gonna be okay it might not be this year
and we all love that kind of immediate
results but I feel good about your
chances down
I'd say that just because you said
you're routing from they filter how many
days how many years since Cleveland
wanna go my gosh
- yeah 635 days that's it so seeing that
and you're right just the feeling of
when he came in the game cuz I was just
watching as a football fan but boy boy
when he came in and you could feel it I
suddenly became invested in that game so
Walking Dead returns for season 9
against Sunday October 7th 9th on AMC
the this is too rare for you to be here
in this studio sir please let's do any
time I love coming in the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience